what former FBI director Andy McCabe
admitted on 60 minutes last night should
alarm all of you I didn't know when I'd
be out of the job so I just put my head
down and got to work trying to stabilize
the people around me and do the things
that I felt we needed to do with the
Russia investigation getting cases
opened and getting a special counsel
appointed is there an appropriate
relationship a connection between this
president and our most fearsome enemy
the government of Russia are you saying
that the president is in league with the
Russians I'm saying that the FBI had
reason to investigate that we talked
about why the president had insisted on
firing the director and whether or not
he was thinking about the Russia
investigation and did that impact his
decision and in the context of that
conversation the Deputy Attorney General
offered to wear a wire into the White
House now he was not joking
he was absolutely serious a discussion
of the 25th amendment was was simply rod
raised the issue and discussed it with
me in the context of thinking about how
many other cabinet officials might
support such an effort okay just to sum
up what he just copped to the newly
promoted McCabe out of political disdain
took it upon himself to become the
ultimate resistance hero he's setting in
motion a counter-intel investigation
against a sitting president of the
United States push for a special counsel
and openly discuss her removing the duly
elected president commander-in-chief
from office and folks on the other
networks are calling this guy a patriot
now what a former high ranking FBI
officials think about all this let's
discuss with a couple of the Great's
Kevin Brock was a former FBI assistant
director for Intel and Terry Turchi was
the former deputy assistant director of
counterterrorism in the counter-terror
division Kevin now you recently penned a
piece calling the caves Orient's
embarrassing lies that's a huge
embarrassment and I think
hope I think Terry will agree that for
former FBI agents and I've heard from a
lot of current FBI agents right now that
what Andrew McCabe is doing what he did
last night
further mislead the American people and
actually manipulated the American people
because now suddenly he's a victim after
perpetrating along with journey Jim
Comey severe damage to the FBI because
of their now what we know clear biases
he is going on a book tour to sell books
everyone's selling books all the other
that former FBI guys are all pushing
their book which is just make money
amazing to us so he's trying to
rehabilitate himself but the damage is
done and he continues to do more damage
he has he has claimed as you just
pointed out when he became Acting
Director he went on a binge of opening
cases against the President of the
United States on the 60 Minutes
interview last night he was deceptive
and misleading he stated that he had
clear and article facts for opening up
an F what were those facts I'm still
waiting for the facts well he said well
the president criticized our
investigation that was number one not a
reason for opening up a case he said
that the president directed James Comey
to let Michael Flynn off the hook no he
didn't if you go back and look at James
commis notes he didn't say that he said
that rod Rosenstein was pressure to put
the Russia investigation and so you know
there was all these things that don't
rise to the level of opening up
legitimate he looked really earnest
Terry he looked really earnest this guy
Malcolm Nance was on MSNBC is a former
counter-terror specialist and this is
how he describes Terry McCabe last night
these phrase is taking down an elected
president of bureaucratic coup this is
Donald Trump's characterization of what
the Patriots at the FBI and the
Department of Justice who were defending
the Constitution of the United States
that's all he was doing defending the
Constitution yeah he sure was I'll tell
you Laura
I first of all I couldn't agree more
with what Kevin
said to you and I can't even watch this
again a night without my blood boiling
I'll make three points number one as
Kevin well knows as all of us who've
worked in the FBI in those positions
know what he essentially told us last
night is after having unverified
information for a year in the form of
the Christopher Christopher steel
dossier and then going to the White
House and being angry because former
director Comey had been fired and not
liking the president's demeanor and the
way he delivered words he decided to go
back and that the man was a great threat
to America that's about what we got last
night and that's about what the FBI had
it is embarrassing
it is just egregious and I never thought
in my lifetime I'd see this and it's
interesting that he opened that case in
about may of nineteen of 2017 you know
we had just come off by a couple of
months march/april going back into
January 2017 where guess what had
happened we had the outgoing Obama
administration unmasking people in the
Trump transition team don't tell me that
the collusion is now starting to come
together and it's not all pointing to
the President and Russia it's pointing
it directly at politics in the top layer
of the FBI and Kevin knows and I know
and anybody who's been in those spots up
there on the seventh floor knows that
the FBI agents who were working in those
top positions we're not following the
rules the guidelines or all of the
policies would put together for decades
to protect this what the guys for both
of you what kind of FBI acting director
convenes or takes part in a meeting
about the 25th amendment and removing
the president is that is that part of
what an acting FBI directors
responsibility is to pronounce over
meetings or to take part of them
you should have immediately got up and
excused himself from that meeting and
said I will not be part of this
discussion first of all the FBI has no
jurisdictional interest or abilities in
in the 25th amendment discussion so he
should have immediately recognized he
had he had no role and should not have
been in a meeting Terry
bill Barr just sworn in last week as the
new Attorney General the United States
former and now current how do
he proceeded here I mean it's almost
like the entire FBI has to be dismantled
and kind of reborn to restore its
integrity because a lot of good people
do work there but it's so tainted now
this whole investigation was a fraud
from the outset and it is patently
obvious to anyone we'll take off their
political you know partisan cap and just
look at the facts and I think Andrew
McCabe gave it away last night he gave
it away I thought it was so obvious they
had nothing on Trump exactly and I think
the big problem confronting the new
Attorney General is this and a lot of
people may not want to get into this
discussion as we have a political party
the Democratic Party turning harder and
harder left which in itself is a major
national security risk we also do not
know exactly to this day exactly what
happened in the FBI whether there still
exists within the FBI these kinds of
issues perhaps people appointed by
McCabe before he left and we need to get
to the bottom of all these things that
are still out there in the universe of
all these loose ends
people need to know who orchestrated all
this because it is absolutely just
unbelievable that there is not somebody
behind all of this that pulled it
together and compromise the FBI and
we're not even getting into the fact we
could have had certainly we could have
we could have had anything from bribes
to greed to evil all of these things or
all of these things are factors here
Kevin and I never saw in the FBI
anything like this and in fact we always
prided ourselves as we left you know
pass along the the FBI we found a little
bit better than to the next generation
this didn't happen this time
all right Rosa stains out bar has this
new deputy Jeff Rossen former partner at
Kirkland and Alice a really good guy is
it time to finally like just let you see
the beginnings that show you need
repercussions for bad behavior will
there be
I have already appealed in articles to
the new Attorney General to launch an
investigation into into the actions of
James Comey and Andrew McCabe these two
these two colluded and fed off each
other's biases to to do a lot of damage
to both of you
credible conversation I know you guys
don't do a lot of TV thank you so much
for joining us tonight